évacuation par la force des acédiques
action simultané au petit matin un peu
partout en France réaction très vive du
Parti communiste des ver les chômeurs
tentent d'autres formes d'action c'est
l'hiver indien en France le Redou
inquiète les agriculteurs les
scientifiques
s'interrogent augmentation dès demain du
pr de l'essence plus 10 centimes à la
pompe la France est l'un des pays
d'Europe où les carburants sont les plus
chers des banques alimentaires pour
venir en aide aux étudiants les plus
démunis l'enquête à Toulouse sur ce
dispositif d'urgence unique en France
mise en place par
l'université alors qu'en France s'achève
aujourd'hui le monopole des pompes
funèbres l'exemple américain découverte
d'un marché particulièrement imaginatif
avec le repos éternel dans
l'espace spectacle enfin avec dans
quelques jours Véronique Sanson sur la
scène du Palais des Sports avant une
tournée en France Véronique Sanson est
notre
invité madame monsieur bonsoir dans le
calme ou par la force évacuation cette
nuit des antennes acédique occupé par
les chômeurs Lionel juspin a fait ce
qu'il a dit et à l'heure qu'il est il
n'y a plus d'occupation par les sans
emplois de ses locaux le mouvement pour
autant ne s'essouffle pas il prend
d'autres formes nous y reviendrons dans
un instant mais voyons sur le terrain là
où le mouvement a commencé à Marseille
comment au petit matin les forces de
l'ordre ont délogé les chômeurs
reportage Yannick carousi jeanvranois
georgetti il est 6h la police lance
l'assaut dans les antennes assidques
occupé un assaut symbolique les chômeurs
qui occupent les lieux depuis 30 jours
n'opposent aucune résistance demander
d'vacuer
leseux je
suis
autorit remercie Monsieur Jos d'un côté
le milliard de l'autre côté la
matraque l'intervention de la police
surprend déconcerte et choque les
occupants on narrêtera pas si pour eux
les pauvres ils ont pas le dro de se
révolter nous on on se révolte et on se
révoltera tant qu'on sera pauvre
voilà de son côté le préfet des bouches
duô tente de recoller les morceaux avec
l'annonce de la mise en vre d'un fond
d'urgence sociale dès lundi nous allons
mettre en place avec des sommes
importantes de l'ordre de 100 millions
entre la part du milliard de l'État pour
les BOUCHES DU rô et l'argent du
département des CAF nous avons à avoir
un fond de l'ordre de 100 millions et
nous allons traiter immédiatement les
dossiers mais ces propositions ne
satisfont pas les sans emplois qui
demandent une prime pour tous et non au
cas par cas alors le mouvement continue
sous diverses formes plusieurs dizaines
de churs occupé la mairie d'Arles
aujourd'hui mi 13 janvier à Marseille
l'heure est à la mobilisation pour la
manifestation de
mardi on insiste encore plus sur la
création d'emplois dans les bouurones là
où on a ple rien malheureusement quoi
d'autres actions ne sont pas exclure
d'ici là comme par exemple un retour
vers les antennes acédiques lundi matin
à ras maintenant l'évacuation a été
mouvmentée les locaux des ass utés jour
et nuit depuis 27 jours ont été investis
tôt ce matin une personne a légèrement
été blessée aux côtes quelques minutes
avant l'intervention de la police les
chômeurs avaient rangé tout le matériel
qu'ils avaient amassé sur
place la fin des occupation d'acédiic ne
marque pas pour autant la fin du
mouvement des chômeurs exemple à Lyon
cet après-midi où une centaine d'entre
eux ont occupé une ancienne ANPE
appartenant au créy Lionnais une action
de protestation qui a amené les sans
emplois et quelques dizaines de
sympathisants à manifester dans les rues
de la
ville et puis comme nous allons le voir
sur les images suivantes autre scénario
à Bordeaux où plus d'un millier de
personnes chômeurs salariés et retraité
ont manifesté à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats et associations pour dire
clairement que la lutte
continue dès cet après-midi lors d'une
conférence de presse les associations de
chômeurs ont condamné très violemment
ces évacuations jugé inacceptables et
appellent les salariés à se joindre à
leur mouvement côté politique quelques
dissonnan sinon quelques fausses notes
au sein de la majorité plurielle les
réactions avec Olivier
carove la démarche violente stupide et
incohérente tenir une conférence de
presse sous l'œil des CRS l'occasion
était trop belle pour les responsable
des associations de chômeurs c'est au
pied d'un immeuble occupé jusqu'à ce
matin qu'ils ont fait connaître leurs
nouvelles ces évacuations sont d'une
certaine manière une nouvelle violence
nous allons les dépasser en amplifiant
notre lutte parce que nous sommes
toujours aussi déterminés appel à la
greffe des salariés demande de soutien
auprès des autres syndicats le but est
aussi de profiter d'un début de
polémique à gauche notamment chez les
alliés du PS dans la gauche plurielle
selon qu'on est ministre ou député
l'avis est parfois très différent sur la
décision de faire évacuer les acédiques
ce que je peux dire c'est que
aujourd'hui disons ilut il faut à la
fois que les assédies trouvent
retrouvent toute leur possibilité de
remplir leur rôle auprès y compris de
ceux qui veulent se faire inscrire qui
attendent je crois que tout cela est
tout à fait normal on utilise la force
alors qu'il suffisait de poursuivre le
dialogue poursuivre la concertation je
pense que il eû été mieux et plus
conforme à ce qui'est une politique de
gauche de poursuivre ce qui avait été
engagé plutôt que d'envoyer les CRS
c'est quelque chose de lamentable
puisque les réponses du gouvernement
laissaient un espoir sur la forme on
avait reçu les associations de chômeurs
décevé sur le fond visiblement la
concertation devait se poursuivre
envoyer les forces de l'ordre pour
évacuer les assédiques n'est en aucun
cas une réponse aucun commentaire à
Matignon ou Lionel Jospin recevait
aujourd'hui Laurent Fabius le président
de l'Assemblée nationale une assemblée
où la majorité parlementaire semble
avoir de plus en plus de mal à éviter la
cacophonie dans un sondage publié demain
dans le journal du dimanche les Français
donnent leur opinion sur le mouvement
des chômeurs 22 % pensent que les
mesures annoncées vont permettre de
résoudre rapidement le conflit et 77
pensent le contraire par ailleurs la
création du fond d'urgence sociale est
considérée comme un effort financier
important par 59 % des personnes
interrogées peu important 37 % enfin
plus généralement 50 % des Français font
confiance au gouvernement pour lutter
contre l'exclusion et 47 % ne le pensent
pas le le président de la République de
corè où il était venu présenter ses vœux
a réaffirmé que les Français ne croient
pas que réduire le temps de travail
réduira le chômage jaces Chirac a élargi
d'ailleurs le champ de son discours en
enchaînant sur l'augmentation des impôts
reportage Véronique
saintolive ah comment vas-tu ça va encis
Jacques Chirac est chez lui le protocole
est rédu au minimum Bernadette élu local
est là on se tutoie on s'embrasse on se
rappelle de vieilles histoires
ici loin du Premier ministre qu' avait
accompagné tout au long d'une semaine de
vœux le président de la République a
réuni dans une sorte de best of toutes
ses mises en garde à l'égard de la
politique menée par Lionel Jospin et
dans le contexte du conflit des chômeurs
le président de la République s'est posé
en défenseur du dialogue social le moyen
aussi pour lui de manifester son
opposition au projet gouvernemental sur
les 35
heur qui ne voit le danger dans ce
domaine
de méthodes qui imposerai des solutions
uniformes sans tenir compte des
différences dans un monde de plus en
plus
concurrentiel les Français le savent
bien qui dans leur immense majorité ne
croi pas que réduire le temps de
travail qui est par ailleurs une
évolution naturelle et légitime réduira
le
chmage de la le prier secrétaire
socialiste N
venant de celui qui a soutenu une
politique qui pendant 4 ans n'a pas
marché en matière de lutte contre le
chômage par rapport à celui qui avait
cru comprendre ce que voulaient les
Français je pense que il y a une erreur
d'interprétation et que ce gouvernement
a raison de tout tenter de tout engager
et notamment dans le contexte
d'aujourd'hui pour lutter contre le
chômage avec ses pics et ses mises en
garde à l'égard de la politique du
gouvernement de Lionel Jospin Jacques
Chirac montre ainsi sa volonté de
s'impliquer directement dans tous les
grands dossiers à quelques semaines des
élections régional le président de la
République prend ainsi les Français à
témoin et se positionne aussi tout
naturellement comme le leader de
l'opposition ces déclarations du
président de la République s'inscrivent
dans une semaine difficile pour le
Premier ministre et Arlet chabo depuis
son arrivée au pouvoir c'est à
l'évidence la première épreuve de
Lionnel juspin oui le gouvernement n'a
pas vu venir ce mouvement l'a mal évalué
surtout a sous-estimé son écho dans
l'opinion conséquence après les
dissonances des ministres le
gouvernement a été débordé sur sa gauche
accusé de ressembler aux socialistes
gestionnaire et insensible des années 80
en un mot il a raté ce qu'il avait
réussi avec le conflit des routiers
alors hier Lionel Jospin a renoué avec
sa méthode écoute négociation il a
effacé les mots qui ont pu blesser
débloqué des crédit tout en respectant
les impératifs budgétaires et au nom de
l'équilibre le dialogue a été suivi de
la fermeté avec les évacuations de cette
nuit dans quelques jours avec le débat
sur les 35 he le Premier ministre va
montrer sa volonté de trouver de
nouvelles solution au chômage et sans
doute pourra ressouder la gauche au sens
large face aux réticences du patronat du
CNPF et à la mobilisation de la droite
on l'a vu appuyé encore aujourd'hui par
le chef de l'État lui-même mais même si
le gouvernement sort de cette affaire
dans les jours qui viennent et on vient
de voir le scepticisme de l'opinion et
bien ce mouvement constitue une alerte
et sonne une série de rappels pour le
gouvernement d'abord l'espoir suscité
par l'arrivée de la gauche au pouvoir
comparable aux attentes suivant
l'élection de Jacques Chirac sa volonté
de lutter contre la fracture sociale
bref l'urgence de lutter contre
l'exclusion second rappel la nécessité
pour tout pouvoir de garder sa
sensibilité en évitant les attitudes
technocratique et enfin la difficulté de
diriger une majorité plurielle hier
Lionel Jospin confiait qu'il avait à
nouveau mesuré l'extrême fragilité
sociale de la France et bien on écho à
cette fragilité du pays il y a aussi la
fragilité des gouvernements merci Arlet
Chabot la façade de l'Assemblée
nationale a été entièrement recouverte
cet après-midi par le texte du célèbre
jacuse d'Émil Zola un siècle après
l'affaire drefus la Une du journal
L'Aurore s'étale sur 150 m Carr à côté
des colonnes du Palais Bourbon et
restera déployé pendant une
semaine enfin toujours au chapitre
politique nous apprenons le décès de
Marie-Madeleine dienèche ancienne
secrétaire d'État aux Affaires sociales
dans les années 68 70 celle qui fut une
pionnière de la 5e République l'une des
premières femmes en politique et des
hier à l'âge de 83
ans le sujet de conversation et sur
toutes les lèvres la France découvre
l'hiver indien le thermomètre s'envole
une anomalie climatique qui intrigue les
scientifiques le Redou inquiète les
agriculteurs particulièrement dans le
Sud-Ouest David bazier Philippe dum
maille on appelle ça l'hiver indien 18
de5 il y a 3 jours à Bordeaux 20°gr à
Biaritz la même journée le Sud-Ouest bas
des records d'il y a 13 ans chez Météo
France Aquitaine on enregistre mais sans
fièvre les 10 premiers jours de 1998
sont à l'image de
97 cette température relativement douce
est à rapprocher d'une année 97
relativement douce aussi puisque ça a
été l'année depuis 1921 la plus chaude
dans la région bordelaise avec 14 de9 et
et aussi la plus chaude dans la région
Aquitaine ou midi pyrénée puisque nos
collègues de Toulouse Blagnac ont
enregistré des moyennes de température
record de l'ORD de 14 9 et du côté de
pot de 14 de une année printemps que
l'on retrouve dans les arbres fruitiers
dans cette exploitation en cette saison
les vergers ont besoin de température en
dessous de 7°gr mais dopé par la douceur
les bourgeons ont pris un mois
d'avance si cette température douce
continue et bien nous aurons une
floraison des artiers très précoces en
particulier pour le pêcher peut-être
dèsès le 15 février la nature accélère
est-ce le réchauffement de la planète
les scientifiques sont intrigués mais
sans réponse seule certitude le froid
d'hiver va bel et bien revenir la
semaine prochaine aux États-Unis même
phénomène climatique notamment à
Washington qui découvre un printemps
plus que précoce avec record de chaleur
battu à New York jeudi et à Washington
hier les fameux cerisiers du Japon sont
déjà en
fleur à partir de demain l'essence
coûtera plus cher plus 10 CEN à la pompe
pour tous les carburants une hausse qui
était prévue et qui place la France dans
le Plon de tête des pays européens je
chap
rich 2 voitures en double fil nous
sommes à la station d'essence Leclair de
Levalois en région parisienne les
automobilistes avertis prennent leur mal
en patience objectif faire le plein de
carburant avant l'augmentation deain de
centimes
ça vous
va espne c'est beaucoup moins cher la
différence pres dans FR en France le
super s plom devrait passer à 6 fran0 en
moyenne le gazol à 450 le relèvement de
la taxe intérieure sur les produits
pétroliers permet à l'état de récolter
plus de 4 milliards de francs
supplémentaires dans le budget
1998 il y a d'autres solution je
pense toujour les G a voiture comm moi
c'est France confirme en tout cas son
titre de championne d'Europe des taxes
pétrolières elle représente plus de 80 %
du prix à la pompe résultat à 6 franc 40
le litre le super samplon français est
le plus cher d'Europe après les Pays-Bas
le carburant le moins cher se trouve au
Luxembourg 4 frans58 en moyenne côté
Gasol à 4 fr50 le litre la France reste
au-dessus de la moyenne européenne bien
plus cher que le Gasol grec que l'on
peut acheter à 3 fran44 amen les
chauffeurs de bus sont en grève depuis
ce matin pour protester contre les
agressions dont ont été victime deux
d'entre eux le trafic ne devrait pas
reprendre normalement avant
mardi amant la jolie démantellement d'un
réseau de raquette qui obligeit quelques
commerçant du valfouré à payé en échange
d'une hypothétique protection dans la
pure tradition du système mafieux
reportage Vincent enguyen Luc bachof au
pied des tours du valfouré le bar du
quartier arbore une vitrine neuve c'est
pour ne pas voir à la changer de nouveau
que le patron ne tient pas à nous parler
la police vient grâce à lui de
démanteler un réseau d'extorsion de
fonds auprès des commerçants de la cité
il en était lui-même victime après le
saccage de son établissement par une
bagare générale des raquetteurs se
proposent de devenir ses protecteurs
boyennant un impôt de 40000 francs mais
3 mois plus tard la taxe atteint 100000
francs exaspéré le patron de barre
alerte la police planques et filatures
sont alors confié à deux brigades de la
PJ de Versailles nous avons demandé à la
victime de continuer
à répondre aux sollicitations de ces
raquetteurs et à partir de là nous avons
répondu à nous également à toutes les
sollicitation parceque nous sommes allés
à tous les rendez-vous et lorsque la
dernière au dernier rendez-vous les
raquetteurs venaient récupérer l'argent
nous nous étions présents et nous avons
pu les interpeller en flagrant délit de
remise d'argent de la victime à ses
raquetteurs la scène s'est déroulée en
centrreville quatre personnes âgé de 21
à 29 ans sont arrêtés de frères de
nationalité turqu semblent être les
meneurs chez l'aîné non loin du bar
raqueté on retrouve ces deux fusils à
pompe qui servaient à intimider les
victimes pour l'instant seulement trois
commerçants ont déclarer à la police
avoir fait l'objet d'un raquette il
pourrait y en avoir d'autres mais
peut-être craignent-ils les représailles
de quelques complices encore en
liberté le docteur Xavier d'or une
nouvelle fois interpellé avec 40 autres
manifestants anti-avortement devant une
clinique parisienne Xavier d'or avait
été condamné il y a quelques jours à une
amende de 60000 francs ce militant
antivg a déjà fait l'objet de 11
condamnations et on apprend à l'instant
qu'il a été remise en liberté une
enquête nationale sur les conditions de
vie des étudiants révèl que 70 % d'entre
eux proviennent de familles favorisées
reste que les autres connaissent des
situations très disparate allant jusqu'à
la précarité pour venir en aide à ces
étudiants démunis à Toulouse s créé une
banque alimentaire solution d'urgence
mise en place par l'université l'enquête
de Nathalie Moisan et d'Emmanuel
becck
alors on a pasçu de aujourd'hui par
contre on a
reçua des conserves du riz des gâteaux
pour une distribution gratuite et
pourtant nous ne sommes pas au resto du
cœur ou dans les locaux d'une
association caritative mais à
l'Université Paul Sabatier de Toulouse
les étudiants qui viennent là ont moins
de 1500 francs par mois pour
vivre n'a rien depuis 2 mois elle V de
ses économies
attendant Bour qui ser fin janvier j'ai
attendu quand même de mois d'aller voir
l'assistante sociale et elle m'a dirigé
vers ce service et ça vous arrange ça
vous soulage ah oui beaucoup parce que
disons que je mangeais pas beaucoup quoi
durant ces de mois j'ai B c'est vrai
qu'on on évite de faire appel à une
banque alimentaire tant qu'on le peut
bon j'ai utilisé toutes mes ressources
ce qui fait que bon n'ayant pas le choix
c'est vrai que maintenant ça aide quoi
une aide une solution d'urgence
ponctuelle pour C étudiante en 3e année
de biologie qui voudrait être professeur
des écoles
Annelis vit ici chez sa mère seule car
celle-ci invalide est en maison de repos
et ses frères sont placés en famille
d'accueil ou en
foyer j'ai des frins qui sont assez non
famili je dire ils s'occupent de leur
petite vie et celle des autres bah il se
débrouill tout seul et seul avec des
aides réduites vous arrivez à boucler
votre budget euh pas du tout c'est déjà
un miracle que que ça passe le mois quoi
comme Anelise une cinquantaine
d'étudiants bénéficient de l'aide de la
fac une semaine ce sont des tickets de
restaurant universitaires l'autre des
produits récupéré gratuitement auprès de
la Banque Alimentaire
officielle c'était du lait concentré
ouais et il nous a pas proposé de lait
alors est-ce qu'on peut on peut revenir
prendre du lait là la fac fait son
marché comme la Croix Rouge où les sœurs
Francis
et pourtant cette aide ne couvre pas
tous les besoins car le nombre de
bénéficiaires est volontairement limité
à 50 pour 30000 étudiants tout
simplement pour des pour une raison de
de moyens de de logistique entre
guillemets on essaie de de ne pas faire
en sorte que ce ce chiffre explose
auquel cas on pourrait pas subvenir
correctement on donnerait de yaourts à
chaque étudiant pour de semaines ça
rerait à rien il y a de plus en plus
d'étudiants dans les universités c'estàd
que que ces dernières années
l'université s'est démocratisée et que
toutes les couches sociales viennent
maintenant à l'université donc c'est
vrai que ces couches sociales sont
touchés par le chômage en particulier de
plus en plus d'étudiants modestes à
l'université mais aussi un système
d'aide et de Bours inadapté le
gouvernement qui prépare en ce moment
une réforme présentera au printemps au
Parlement un plan social étudiant et
puis cette information que nous transmet
le secrétariat d'État la santé un cas de
méningite sur un vol d' France po à
Pitre Paris du 2 janvier amène la
compagnie à recommander à tous les
passagers par simple mesure de
prévention à consulter un médecin ou
appeler un numéro d'urgence il s'agit du
01 43 37 31
50 l'exode des Kurdes se poursuit en
Italie une cinquantaine de clandestins
dont 10 CDES irakiens ont été
interceptés comme les autres ils ont
tenté la traversere sur des embarcations
de fortune l'Italie depuis quelques
semain est confronté à un afflux de
clandestins CDES les polices de
différents pays européens se sont
d'ailleurs réunis ces jour-ci la France
n'est pas épargnée en 97 près de 4000
CDES ont été interpellés un chiffre en
augmentation même si la France n'est pas
une terre de prédilection reportage à
Paris sur cette communauté qui
représente dans notre pays près de
100000 personnes agè varamian Dominique
Bonet Jimy a quitté son pays à 20 ans
elle a déjà passé anné en France après
un studio à Paris elle occupe maintenant
avec ses deux enfants et son mari ce
petit de pièces en banlieu du Kurdistan
de leur village de paysans et d'éleveurs
de moutons il gardent ses quelques
photos alors même qu'il n'était pas
militant politique la répression turque
dis les a fait
fuir j'ai été souvent placé en garde à
vue par des policiers j'ai été 3 mois en
détention j'ai eu peur pour ma vie et
j'ai décidé de partir avec mes
enfants c'est aussi pour des raisons
politiques que le frère et un cousin de
la famille disent être venu en France il
y a quelques mois une arrivée
clandestine qui depuis la Turquie a
coûté à ses deux garçons 300
Fran j'ai traversé l'Italie avec un
Allemand qui juste pour me faire passer
la frontière française m'a pris 2500
francs il a franchi le poste de Douine
se en voiture il m'a laissé sur la route
juste avant à pied par les collines et
lui m'a récupéré ensuite côté
français aujourd'hui si personnes
s'entassent dans ce logement car les
CDES sont solidaires tout nouvel
arrivant est pris en charge par une
communauté regroupée ici dans le 10e
arrondissement de Paris les CDES ont
investi des commerces créé 50
associations et sont très politisé dans
ce local des sympathisants proch des
partis séparatist écoutent la chaîne
curde par satellite et réagissent à
l'exode le seul désir de la Turquie
c'est que les gens
partent ils veulent dépeupler le
Kurdistan si la Turquie ne les forçait
pas à partir ces gensl resterai au
pays comme la plupart des CDES de France
jy et sa famille ont demandé l'asile
politique un seul son frère qui
travaille aussi dans cet atelier l'a
obtenu demande a été refusée car on m'a
dit que les preuves de persécution conc
mon frère et pas MOI
mais j'ai dit comment ça ne me concerne
pas toute ma famille a eu des problèmes
avec la police Jamy ne veut pas
retourner en Turquie régulièrement elle
verse de l'argent à des organisations
politiques jusqu'à 1000 francs par mois
la seule façon dit-elle d'aider son
peuple nouveau massacre en Algérie plus
de 40 personnes ont été assassinées lors
de différentes attaques dans l'ouest du
pays et au sud d'Alger ces deux derniers
jours une nouvelle fois des femmes et
des enfants atrocement mutilés se
trouvent parmi les
victimes le séisme monétaire en Corée du
Sud amène les autorités à lancer une
campagne nationale d'urgence pour
renflouer les réserves appel à la
solidarité des citoyens qui participent
à cet effort de guerre en apportant
leurs bijoux en or qui sont par la suite
traités et refondus William
Irigoyen jamais les fourgons coréens
n'auront été autant sollicités à
l'intérieur de ces forteresses blindées
des sacs qui dissimulent des milliers
d'objets en or
des clés des bagues toutes sortes de
bijoux déposés depuis 5 jours par les
Coréens qui répondent à l'appel lancé
par le
gouvernement ces objets de valeur vont
être ensuite fondus et transformés en
lingot puis ils seront vendus sur les
marchés internationaux contre des
dollars
américains l'état coréen veut répondre
aux attaques spéculatives et éviter la
faillite alors que la crise financière
touche de plein fouet les différentes
places boursières en
asieux qui sont portés volontaires
seront rémunérés dans un mois en one la
monnaie nationale le sens civique a donc
prévalu en Corée une bonne partie de la
population s'est d'ors et déjà mobilisé
le montant de l'or déposé s'élèvera à
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
francs et puis on apprend à l'instant
que 160 kg de cocaïne ont été découverts
par les douaniers britanniques dans une
voiture qui tentait d'entrer en
Grande-Bretagne par le tunnel sous la
Manche il s agit de l'une des plus
importantes saisies a affirmé l'un des
responsables de l'enquête en France
depuis aujourd'hui a pris fin le
monopole des pompes funèbres un marché
qui s'offre donc à la concurrence comme
aux États-Unis où depuis des années les
sociétés rivalisent d'imagination
découverte de ce repos éternel dans
l'espace un voyage intercidéral sur les
catalogues des entreprises funéraire
Philippe
gasso
le tour récent lancement de Lunar
prospecteur la sonde lunaire est sans
doute l'enterrement le plus coûteux du
monde car en dehors des appareil de
mesure la sonde emporte dans ses flancs
les cendres du pionnier desmission
Apollo Eugène Schumacher elle tourneront
pendant 1 an avant de s'éparpiller sur
le sol lunaire coût total de l'opération
378 millions de francs cependant pour
les enterrements cosmique nous avons
bien meilleur marché mais pour aller
aussi beaucoup moins loin grâce à C une
société de pompes funèbr basée au Texas
on vous propose un voyage postmem en
orbite terrestre la première expérience
a eu lieu en avril dernier et le marché
semble
porteur il y a environ 2 millions de
crémtion par an dans des pays comme les
USA le Japon l'Allemagne l'Angleterre et
cetera et si nous arrivons à prendre ne
serait-ce qu'un tout petit pourcentage
du marché de la crémation nous aurons
une activité
florissante pour le premier lancement 24
pionniers postumes ont fait le voyage
dont Timothy lerry le célèbre gourou du
Peace and Love apôtre des paradis
artificiels qui a voulu sans doute
s'offrir un dernier pétard pour la
route un deuxième départ est en
préparation et pour 30000 francs vous
aurez une vue imprenable sur la planète
bleue les cendres de chaque passager
sont serrés dans une capsule du M
identifié et c'est les uns contre les
autres que le tout est fixé sur la fusée
ensuite bonjour les étoiles une façon de
faire un bout de chemin en direction du
Très-Haut une évolution dans la
profession des pompes funèbres qui
n'intéresse pas que des
illuminé ma mère était une personne qui
voulait vraiment vivre l'an 2000 et je
crois que cette idée lui aurait
plu c'est vraiment un plus pour notre
métier que de pouvoir offrir cela à nos
familles à nos
clients la profession y croit et verrait
même une exploitation de l'espace à plus
grande échelle à un moment où l'encombr
est un problème dans nos cimetières
classiques retour sur la planète à grass
les producteurs de truff des Alpes
Maritimes organise un marché de la
truffe chez l'un des plus grands chefs
de France journée de dégustation de ce
champignon très recherché Yasmina Farber
Dian Richard ambiance gardeon partie
dans le jardin de la Bastie de
Saint-Antoine sous les tentes les
visiteurs sont à la poursuite du diamant
noir il chasse la truffe la plus
odorante celle qui parfumera le mieux
les ma les plus divers
la Provence fournit 30 % de la
production de la truffe noire la fameuse
tuber
Mélanosporum ce n'est pas que que le sol
qui fait qui fait qui est favorable à la
truffe c'est aussi le microclimat hein
et c'est le microclimat les alternances
chaudes et humide de de l'été qui font
sortir ce champignon on dit sortir mais
en fait il sort pas c'est un champignon
souterrain et pour flairer le champignon
caché au pied des chaînes blancs ou des
chaînes verts la truff des chiens fait
des miracles
les truficulteurs les ont adopté pour
laisser les truis de côté on se sent mal
de promoner avec un cochon aujourd'hui
et c'est plus pratique de promoner avec
un chien et ça va beaucoup plus vite
parce que on n pas trop le temps donc on
va 1hure le soir 1 heure le matin et ça
il faudrait déjà une heure pour prendre
le cochon et le mener sur la place pour
travailler car le temps c'est de
l'argent la saison est moyenne pour la
récolte des truffes le kilo vaut 2500
francs alors il vaut mieux savoir
cuisiner à l'économie
avec 30 g de truff et 6 ufs donc vous
faites le compte ça revient pas
tellement cher que ça et bien entendu
s'il veulent mieux alors il s'adressent
à côté de chez moi là chez mon collègue
Chibois alors là ils auront toute la
gamme de tout ce qui peut se faire avec
la Tru il faut il faut être généreux
hein la truve ça doit se manger et puis
les gens viennent pour manger la truve
aussi c'est la fit de la truff c'est une
promotion c'est une défente de ce beau
produit c'est une chose mythique donc
on dans les cuisines des grands
restaurants seul le chef a le droit de
manipuler la truffe pour ne pas l'abîmer
jaces Chib a mis le champignon à toutes
les sauces même sucré le diamant noir se
marie très bien au caramel de ce pain
perdu au
pomm nous recevons maintenant Véronique
Sanson bonsoir vous êtes à quelques
jours de votre spectacle au Palais des
sports on y reviendra mais tout de suite
l'ambiance des derniers moments la
fébrilité des répétitions Louis
Carzou
ce n'est point l'être idéal c'est plutôt
du réconfort que semble rechercher
Véronique sans car à la veille de son
retour sur une scène parisienne après
plus de 3 ans d'absence cet artiste
connu pour son TR ne cherche même pas à
démentir le sentiment qui nous parfois s
refrain certes le Palais des Sports est
pour elle un lieu familier début ici dat
d'il y 20 ans mais sortie de son nouvel
album est retardé au mois de février de
quoi insuffler un peu plus encore un
léger vent de folie sur ses
répétitions mais quand je
Meille tout mon corps se balance dans un
nouveau
sommeil dans C ver
so et grand
alléluia
c'est vrai qu'il a un vent de folie et
qu' a une pression énorme sur B sur tout
le monde un petit peu mais c'est pas que
négatif je crois que c'est il y a
beaucoup de choses positives sur les
pressions et les
urgencesage
c'est donc sur scène que le public
s'apprête à découvrir le nouvel album de
Véronique Sanson un Paris un peu fou
mais justement le titre encore
provisoire de ce nouveau disque c'est
fou en
verlan 10 jours donc au Palais des
Sports une tournée un nouvel album en
regardant ces images on a l'impression
qu'à chaque fois vous avez le track et
que c'est peut-être encore plus
difficile de refire de la scène quand on
a pas fait depuis quelques années bien
sûr je crois que c'est de plus en plus
difficile parce qu'on on est très
conscient on est de plus en plus
conscient de de ce qui peut se passer et
on est plus de plus en plus bourré de
doute sur ce qu'on peut être soi-même et
que rien n'est jamais acquis et comme
c'est un un métier je veux pas dire un
métier mais un état de
grâce très aléatoire et
très rien rien n'estquis quoi rien tombe
dans la bouche tout cru dans le bec
malgré la foi et l'expérience que vous
avez ce qui ce qui m'étonne c'est que
j'ai l'impression que vous enregistrez
un album uniquement pour avoir la chance
de refaire de la scène c'est vrai c'est
vrai non mais c'est bien de faire des
chansons aussi mais j'aime pas qu'on
qu'on me pressurise pour faire des
chansons moi je fais des chansons j'ai
il faut que j'ai le temps de d'observer
les gens vous par exemple ou tous les
gens qui nous entourent et d'avoir le
recul nécessaire pour pouvoir mettre en
mot ce que je ressens et ce que
j'observe ce que j'observe de moi-même
aussi mes peines mes joies et pour
pouvoir les partager avec les autres la
scène c'est un peu votre votre univers
je dirais même votre
respiration c'est toute ma vie si je
peux plus y aller c'est c'est un drame
c'est que je serai
morte alors Barbara la chanteuse Barbara
je crois assister à votre première
Olympia depuis c'était créé une
connivance une complicité entre vous oui
très grande même si on se voyait pas
très souvent je sais qu'elle est venue
au premier Olympia et qu'elle était là
comme ça avec son écharpe et qu'elle m'a
dit t'inquiète pas ma grande elle
m'appelait ma grande et moi je
l'appelais ma petite et qu'est-ce
qu'elle vous aurait dit pour vous
encourager aujourd'hui elle m'aurait dit
de ne de ne de ne jamais douter parce
qu'elle elle doutait tout le temps
et elle m'aurait dit elle m'aurait
encouragé elle m'aurait et je suis sûre
qu'elle est là et qu'elle sera là il y a
quelques jours le le journal Le Monde
publia un portrait de Johnny alider une
sorte de confession à portrait assez
désemparé très dur très solitaire de de
la star est-ce que votre vérité pourrait
ressembler à la
sienne mais je crois qu'on a tous des
vérités qui sont les mêmes simplement il
y a des moments euh où on se sent de les
dire et de et de les de les de les
exorciser et je pense que
peut-être que Johnny a a eu un coup de
blouse et a eu un moment de tristesse ou
un moment où il a voulu dire exactement
ce qu'il était moi je sais pas je je il
y a de la détresse ce désaris chez vous
et peut-être chez tous les artistes mais
je crois que chez tout le monde c'est
pas que les artistes c'est les gens qui
qui sont boulangers qui sont crémiés qui
qui se baladent dans la rue qui vont au
bureau et tout le monde a des moments de
détresse épouvantable simplement les
gens peuvent pas les
exprimer comme ils veulent les exprimer
alors je voudrais qu'on qu'on parle d'un
tout autre sujet il y a quelques années
à l'Olympia vous vous aviez chanté une
chanson qui s'appelait Allah qui vous
avait valu un certain nombre de menaces
depuis et peut-être même avant vous êtes
quelqu'un qui est impliqué toujours
proche de l'actualité et concerné par
l'Algérie mais c'est pas l'Algérie moi
je suis concernée par l'intolérance et
par le fanatisme et c'est et c'est c'est
ça qui qui m'importe que ce soit en
Afghanistan que ce soit l'Inquisition
par
exemple j'aime pas le fanatisme j'aime
pas qu'on qu'on empêche les gens de
penser ce qu'ils ont envie de penser et
puis surtout d'aller d'aller dans des
maisons et de fracasser des bébés et de
de tuer des femmes et des hommes
simplement sur dénonciation ça me fait
beaucoup penser au nazi ça me fait
penser au
au à à une espèce de de de répression et
un
obscurantisme affreux affreux et une
désinformation
qui est très importante alors à Moot
encore les restos du cœur Sean si on a
le sentiment que vous avez besoin dans
votre vie d'être utile de tendre la main
de faire quelque chose et d'agir ça
c'est aussi votre vérité je crois que la
seule chose qu'on puisse faire nous
c'estàd qu' ne sommes pas des politiques
qui ne sommes pas des
économistes la seule chose qu'on puisse
donner au monde c'est notre art au
service des gens qui sont démunis et et
et de les soutenir et c'est la seule
chose qu'on puisse faire et c'est c'est
c'est la moindre chose ben vous le
faites très bien et merci en tout cas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et merci
de m'avoir reçu après la fureur des
tamagchis ce petit animal virtuel vendu
par millions dans le monde entier voici
qui arrive sur le marché le partenaire
des jeunes sous la même forme mais pour
adultes un nouvel apprentissage de
l'amour pas plus grand qu'un porte-clé
présentation à Tokyo au salon du jouet
hervu brzini
ici on ne badine pas avec l'amour
électronique désormais adolescentes et
adolescents japonais pourront faire leur
apprentissage du cœur grâce à cette
petite chose l'amour est virtuel
programmable à souer on peut choisir le
sexe du compagnon garçon ou fille lui
offrir des cravates ou des diamants pour
finalement l'épouser et regarder la télé
en couple le rêve quoi
la notice nous donne plus ample
information il n'est pas nécessaire d'en
prendre soin lorsqu'il est en mode
travail ou étude cela réduit votre
dérangement autrement dit l'amour quand
il est électronique n'est pas une
occupation à plein temps contrairement
au tamagosi ce petit animal tout aussi
virtuel qui exigeait une attention de
chaque instant les clients souhaité
paraîil quelque chose de mieux de moins
astraignant les voilà servis
je crois que cette idée de jeu est assez
saine ça aide les adolescents à avoir
l'expérience de l'amour et ils
apprennent à se
respecter le respect en trois dimensions
dat Kyoko jeune chanteuse virtuelle
l'enseignait déjà son clip fut un succès
retentissant avec pour titre amour
communication il y a donc l'amour la vie
et la mort où l'on se recueille devant
sa Stelle informatique le tout
électronique est en place ça se vend par
million et pas seulement au Japon mais
si cette formation était défaillante les
marchands de jouet Nipon vous proposent
aussi
cela une autre manière certainement de
voir l'apprentissage de la
vie ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres
évacuation par les forces de l'ordre des
assédiques action simultané au petit
matin un peu partout en France réaction
très vive du Parti communiste des ver
les chômeurs tentent d'autres formes
d'action augmentation dès demain du prix
de l'essence plus 10 centimes à la pompe
la France est l'un des pays d'Europe où
les carburants sont les plus
chers dans un instant la météo Laurent
remeschco soleil et grande douceur 20h55
la fiesta Patrick Sébastien 2ain 7h dans
thé ou café Catherine sellac reçoit
charlesellie couture midi polémique
Michel cotta aura pour invité
Jean-Claude guessou ministre de
l'équipement et des transports je vous
remercie de votre attention j'auraai le
plaisir de vous retrouver demain à 20h
excellente FEM soirée sur France